the drug itself is called semaglatide
and the brand name is ozempic but
shortly after these drugs were being
prescribed to people with type 2
diabetes Physicians and scientists found
that people were losing weight as well
which is generally good because people
with type 2 diabetes are often
overweight or if you're clinically obese
it predisposes you to type 2 diabetes
and so after a couple of years the drug
was prescribed by physicians off label
to help people with weight loss and then
in 2021 the FDA reapproved some aglatide
under a different brand name wegovi
specifically to help people to lose
weight it seems to me there's an
interesting back door here that you're
describing because if FDA approves a
drug for whatever reason and you find
another application for that drug it
doesn't have to be FDA approved again is
that correct that's why everybody loves
the little blue pill